well christmas is coming fast and I
wanted to use this time to explain how
tradition works and how it can help us
understand symbolism what I want to do
is is look at the traditional icon of
the Nativity of Christ and focus on a
few elements there especially the
elements which are not present in
Scripture I want to look at the ass and
the Ox
as well as the idea of the cave in which
Christ was born
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
the details of the birth of Christ and
the Gospels are actually pretty spares
and so many of the details of how we
proceed the Christian story actually
come from tradition for example the
Bible doesn't say that they were three
Magi
it just says that they were Magi even
though many modern Protestants have been
hostile to a non biblical tradition
these traditions persist nonetheless and
we'll look at why they do and maybe how
that works one of the traditions that
has persisted since the beginning of
Christianity has been the notion that
there's an ass and an ox present when
Christ was born at first this might seem
like a nice sentimental addition to the
story let's say of how cute it is or
maybe you know just a boring admonition
that since you know it says that Christ
was laying in a manger that is an animal
food trough well then there must have
been animals by the way the Bible
doesn't say that Christ was born in a
stable it just said that he was laying
in a major but we'll get to that the
addition of the ass and the ox is
actually the most persistent element in
the visual representation of the birth
of Christ after the actual Christ child
laying in a manger there are very early
images where all that is shown is Christ
with the animals to signify his birth so
why is this well there's a prophecy in
the Book of Isaiah which says the ox
knows his owner and the ass his master's
crib but Israel has not known me and my
people have not understood so of course
we're so used to you know using the word
crib to me in a baby's bed that we don't
realize that a crib is a manger that a
crib is a feeding trough for animals and
even though the the detail of the ass
and the ox isn't
in Scripture what it does is that it
will add some connections connections in
the patterns which will help us
understand what this moment means what
the Incarnation means early Christians
were soon to point out that the ox and
the ass were two different types of
animals the Ox was a pure animal
according to Old Testament purity laws
and the ass was an impure animal and so
having them come together at the manger
signifies the ultimate unity of those
opposites a place where the separated
things can come together
continuing the analogy for writers early
Christian writers as early as Origen the
Ark's represented the Israelites and the
ass represented the foreigners and
bringing them together was the image of
how Christ and the church
had United the inside and the outside in
the Israelites and the foreigners like
like I discussed in my video on purity
laws there's a law in the Old Testament
which prescribes yoking and ass and an
ox together that is bringing together
the pure and the impure and in a very
powerful way Christ becomes the place
where that is nonetheless possible and
the fact that this happens around a
manger is very important because the
place where that happens for Christians
is also in the food of communion look at
the manger in the traditional icon what
does it look like it's a pretty fancy
manger isn't it
the reason why it looks like this is
that it's also supposed to represent a
tomb a sarcophagus actually and so
already showing that the incarnation of
Christ is an entry into death the
swaddling clothes are also the the linen
wrappings that we're going to cover the
body of Christ so for example here is a
traditional icon of the finding of the
empty tomb where Christ was laid and you
can see the sarcophagus and you can see
the empty wrappings and you can see
visually the relationship that that
would be found between the way the
manger is represented and the cloth and
the way the tomb is represented in the
cloth so in the icon the beginning of
life is connected to death the place of
Christ's birth is represented as a cave
this is a very old tradition one that is
attested to in the very in the first
century in Justin Martyr like I said at
the beginning the gospel does not tell
us where Christ was born but when you
imagine it when you represent it there
has to be a place right and by having
that detail of the cave it's not just a
random detail which adds some you know
idiosyncratic tidbit to the story rather
the cave helps us to understand what the
Incarnation is it adds a detail to help
us see something which is already there
implicitly in the notion of the manger
right the lowest place imaginable you
could say and so the cave you know with
the mother of God Mary lying next to
Christ emphasizes this entry into Earth
the the life of God entering into the
lowest place into the opening of the
earth connecting the highest with the
lowest it's similar to how God in
creating man bluespirit into the
nostrils of Adam's as he was made of
Earth I mean of course the Incarnation
is at a whole different level than the
the first creation of man but the
pattern is there nonetheless this is
also the link to communion communion is
very many many things of all the
elements of the Bible communion is
probably one of those things that that
that are inexhaustible in their
implications but one of the implications
of communion is the joining of pure and
impure for although it was common for
people to eat bread
and to eat meat to eat flesh it
certainly was prescribed to drink blood
and in the case of human but blood that
even the coming in contact with human
blood made one immediately in pure
drinking and blood was unacceptable
because the blood was supposed to go
down into the ground poured into the
ground but Christ has United the ground
with the sky United Earth with heavens
now there's another verse to which
Christians refer to when explaining why
there was an ass and an ox at the manger
with Christ and it's a prophecy in
Habakkuk which says between two beasts
you are made manifest now this verse in
Habakkuk is completely lost to us if you
try to find it in your Bible you will
not find it for it's based on the the
seventy version of the Septuagint
tradition of the Bible which for most of
us today we don't have access to but you
see in a way that doesn't matter what we
need to see is the pattern the notion
that Christ would appear between two
beasts makes absolute sense it makes
sense symbolically as the union of
divisions the union of the division
which is flesh think for example of the
seemingly crazy ritual that Abraham does
with God
where he he separates these carcasses in
- right and then God passes through the
middle of these separated carcasses it
would think mostly for example I at the
image of the Ark of the Covenant the box
which was on which was made the
manifestation of the glory of God
well that box had two beasts two cherubs
we represent them as pretty little
angels today but if you look at what a
cherub was in the Old Testament it was
actually a hybrid beast mix of a lion
and a
and an oxen and a man and God manifested
himself in the center of those two
borders of those two extremes right now
look again at the manger in the icon is
it a manger is it a sarcophagus it is is
it the Ark of the Covenant with the two
beasts between which God showed himself
one must remember that in the Ark of the
Covenant was placed the mana the bread
of heaven which was given to Israel in
the desert so the Ark is also a
container for food so you see the
traditions that are added the ass and
the ox the cave and other details are
not arbitrary
they're there to focus to give us one
more hint of the implications of this
moment when God United himself to men
and all of the imagery of the Nativity
is to show us that this point this child
in this manger is a union of the very
lowest with the very highest that is in
it is in fact the center of the cosmic
mystery laying there a child
life-and-death union of pure and impure
the star and the cave the wise three
kings and the lowest of shepherds read
all these traditions woven together to
show us as much as it's possible for us
to see what the center of all things
looks like what that logos is so I wish
you all a wonderful Christmas later this
month as hopefully you're able to
remember you know in the darkest moment
of the year when the Sun is at its
lowest of that hidden flame in the cave
the logos rising out of darkness to fill
the whole world so I'm really excited to
announce that we've reached the level of
1,000 on my patreon account and so I've
got to to catch up with you guys now
at 1,000 we said that I'm going to start
to put out votes for the the patrons on
voting on some of the content and so
I've already started to do that also I'm
starting this month in December it's
there's going to be a monthly seminar
for some of the the higher giving
patrons where we're going to every month
get together and have a discussion and a
seminar on symbolism so it'll be more of
a thread and more of a continual
approach to symbolism so I'm pretty
excited to get involved in to end that
and so so that's what's going on with me
and as usual stay in touch and we'll see
you soon